[Music]
hey I know you boss says you've been
real helpful like but uh that's my nice
way of telling
yeah I don't know what your angle is but
it's too quiet what are you up to out
there hello
yeah and for the hundreds who are oh so
enjoys declare to stop sale to you lot
but even if I don't know how you got
those goons to leave but thank you Bram
ordered rollers and what's it's like I
said it's an enviable thing he's doing
law I should go
what do you I always took that woman for
the sensible type give them all my
regards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm telling you the book welcome back
Thank You Carlotta usually scheduled
this cuts off one of our only about I
the print I've already sent a team ahead
to scout the press one of our best meet
them there and find out if they've been
successful you said they weren't willing
to fight for our cause is a printing
press really worth all these people's
law I have the utmost confidence in
their abilities this is worth big look
just
[Music]
[Applause]
you